this is a time lapse of two brains over
six years this one is normal and this
one has alzheimer's a disease that kills
more than 120 000 people in the u.s
annually and that researchers have spent
more than three decades trying to cure
and it's at the center of controversy
around a new drug called agile there are
a few drugs that are on the market now
they work okay to alleviate some of the
symptoms of alzheimer's but but nothing
that really sort of slows down the
course of this of this disease biogen's
agile aims to change that it might be
the first drug to slow the progression
from here
to here and could delay the loss of
memory and other functions but flawed
trials from the drug maker have led many
medical experts to question the science
and some insurance companies to limit
coverage
here's how agile functions in the brain
and why some doctors won't prescribe it
yet
agile is meant to treat the root cause
of alzheimer's which is a series of
chemical changes in the brain the
disease attacks tiny cells called
neurons which control movement senses
memory and thinking when someone has
alzheimer's communication between
neurons is interrupted and the cells die
researchers aren't sure exactly why this
happens but they found two biomarkers in
the brain that might be factors called
amyloid plaques and tau tangles
everybody needs to have the amyloid
precursor protein and the tau protein
we need them for normal brain function
dr paul aison has been a paid consultant
for biogen and has worked on a range of
treatments for alzheimer's including
agile in alzheimer's disease these
proteins are changed they are modified
in a way that causes them to aggregate
or clump together plaques are made up of
clumps of beta-amyloid which is a sticky
protein that accumulates throughout the
brain scientists think that these
clusters may block communication between
cells tau tangles build up inside of
neurons and block pathways in the cell
for nutrients and other essentials
plaques and tangles as they accumulate
in the brain kill off brain cells and
once brain cells are dead
they're not coming back to life the goal
of adrikanemab the generic name for
ajihelm is to target the amyloid plaques
and hopefully slow down the death of
neurons
it does this using antibodies proteins
in the blood that are programmed to
attack viruses bacteria and other
foreign substances adricanamab is a
monoclonal antibody which means it was
designed in a lab to mimic real ones
made by the immune system attica map in
particular was modeled
on an antibody that occurred in people
who seem to be resistant to alzheimer's
disease when injected the antibodies
travel to the brain through the
bloodstream and latch onto plaques they
then attract natural scavenging cells
called microglia that bind to the
antibody proteins and chew up the clumps
the microglia seem to
digest the material of the plaques and
then bring them into the bloodstream and
the amyloid is cleared through the blood
vessels
in theory once the plaques are removed
accumulation will slow down or stop and
brain cells won't die as quickly this
could delay loss of memory and function
for people who are at an early stage in
the disease and could potentially add
years to their lives if agilent works it
could be a crucial step toward
preventing alzheimer's
but some doctors and researchers aren't
convinced it's effective
since 2019 really the drug has been
super controversial what happened was
biogen was running these two big phase
three trials and then shut them down
prematurely because they thought that
they weren't going to work joseph walker
covers biotechnology and drug companies
and has led reporting on agile's
progress they combined all the data to
do a pooled analysis and then when they
looked at them separately they saw that
the results were different they also saw
that the additional data sort of changed
the picture a bit both trials showed the
drug was effective at reducing the
amount of plaque in the brain but only
one trial showed an effect on patients
decline slowing symptoms from getting
worse by about 22 percent
based on these results the fda granted
agile accelerated approval meaning the
drug was not fully proven to work but
showed promising enough results that it
can be prescribed to patients while
another study is done the agency said
they approved the drug because the need
for treatments is urgent but some
doctors aren't sure there is enough
evidence of the drug's benefits or
safety you just generally don't want to
you know give people things that don't
work you think are like unlikely to and
even more so when a drug has side
effects when it's removing amyloid from
the brain that can cause swelling and
even these small brain bleeds there's
another reason the data has been brought
into question the the idea that simply
removing amyloid from the brain
will slow alzheimer's disease is still
very much contested and so to approve a
drug on that basis for some people is a
little premature another issue is how
much agile costs biogen said the initial
price for treatments over the course of
a year would be about 56 000 for the
average person the sticker shock caused
some insurers to limit coverage and the
price of agile was cut in half in
december 2021
the fact that so many of the health
insurers and doctors have sort of
balked at paying for the drug or
prescribing it i think you know has
thrown sort of some uncertainty into the
picture here other companies also
currently have amyloid targeting
treatments in testing phases
and some researchers hope that agile's
approval is just the first step in
finding a treatment to prevent
alzheimer's it's actually been the most
encouraging results we've seen over the
30 years that we've been working on
slowing this disease so i would say that
on balance even with the controversy the
work on atacama has stimulated and
excited the field agile is currently
approved for early stage patients biogen
will do another trial to confirm it
works but it will likely take years to
get final results
[Music]